[MUSIC PLAYING]
DON DODGE: Hi, I'm Don
Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today we're going to talk
about advisory boards.
Should your startup have
an advisory board?
Who do you look for to find
on that advisory board?
And just how do you do it?
My guest today is David Gurle.
David has been on both
sides of the table.
He's been an adviser to
several companies.
And he's been a CEO who has
built his own advisory board.
So welcome, David.
DAVID GURLE: Thank you
for having for
having me today, Don.
DON DODGE: Great to
have you here.
You're CEO of Perzo,
a new company.
So it's about-- how old
is the company?
DAVID GURLE: Well, since
September, 2012.
So only about six months.
DON DODGE: And do you have
an advisory board?
DAVID GURLE: I do, actually.
I have four people in my
advisory board today.
DON DODGE: So why do you
get an advisory board?
You're an experienced
executive.
You've been around big companies
and startups.
Why do you need an
advisory board?
DAVID GURLE: I think any new
venture has to bring together
a number of talents and
experiences and assets.
Nobody can have it all.
Clearly, the team that you are
building in your organization
has to have anything that helps
you to get the product
to the market.
But even that is
not sufficient.
You need to go to reach out
to other experiences,
complementary ones, sometimes
supplementary ones, so that
you always get a full picture,
the full information before
you make a decision.
And that's the reason I went and
sought the advice of these
four excellent people.
DON DODGE: And do you
look for general
advice, or do you pick--
you have four advisers, so do
you pick one who's great at
marketing and sales?
And do you pick another one
who knows the financial
markets, and another one
who knows engineering?
How do you decide
which advisers?
DAVID GURLE: That's a
very good question.
I think first you have
to look at yourself--
where you are good at and
where you need help.
You can get the team as the
team dynamics come true.
Where is your team
really strong at?
And where they can get better?
And then look at your market.
Where are you going to go?
Are you going to be an
enterprise startup?
Are you going to be a
consumer startup, an
infrastructure startup?
Depending on all those elements,
you have to pick the
right people to complement
you.
And this is really the
important thing.
There's a complementarity
around that.
So in my case, this is
my first startup.
I have done startups in big
companies, but it's very
different when you are
outside on your own.
So I needed the advice of people
who have been in this
situation before and therefore,
who could help me
navigate those hurdles.
I think that's number one.
Number two--
I think you need believers
in you.
Advisers are good
for two things--
first, telling you what they
will recommend given a
situation, but also give
you the morale
boost that you need.
Sometimes when you hit those
bumps in the road, they tell
you, look, David, it's OK.
We're going to walk
it through.
This is how it's done.
And with that kind of energy
that comes from your advisers,
you're able to overcome a bunch
of obstacles you could
otherwise not.
DON DODGE: That's a very
interesting point, because
normally, you think of advisers
as giving deep,
professional advice on legal
matters or financial matters
or engineering or whatever.
But CEOs also need someone that
they can bounce ideas off
of, things like difficult
problems that you couldn't
discuss with your employees
because they're too tragic or
ultimately bad.
So you use the advisers also as
your sounding board, your
cheerleaders.
DAVID GURLE: Coach
and mentors.
And that's really
how I treat--
I hope that this comes across
in this way towards my
advisers-- is that I
think my company's
kind of a sports team.
Maybe it's a soccer team
or a football team.
And the advisers are our
coaches and mentors.
And they've been there.
They are specializing
in different areas.
I can use my advisers to ask
things that I wouldn't ask
other people, because I know
that the relationship is
really strong.
And they are not going
to judge me.
And with that judgment element
out of the equation, it makes
your relationship much simpler,
more straightforward.
What comes out is not you are
good or you're bad, or you
suck on this and you are
really good at that.
It is, OK, well, you have a
difficult situation or you
have a very good situation,
and here are the
right things to do.
And this removes all pressure
that you will get, for
example, from a regular
board or from
potential other investors.
And that's what I like about
surrounding myself with advisers.
Because of those things,
I feel free to
innovate and execute.
DON DODGE: So the sports analogy
is actually a very
good one-- a coach
or a mentor.
Even Michael Jordan, the best
basketball player in the
world, needed a coach.
Or Tom Brady, the quarterback
of the
Patriots, needs a coach.
CEOs think of themselves as
invincible and knowing
everything.
But even they need coaches and
mentors to help them through
some of the tough times.
DAVID GURLE: Absolutely true.
I'm definitely not invincible.
And I think the challenge for
CEOs or wannabe founders is to
understand their
situation well.
And that's where I think
everything starts from.
You have to know what you're
going to be excellent at.
And you have to continue
to be excellent in it.
Michael Jordan was an excellent
basketball player,
but I'm sure that there are
many other areas in his
professional life as a
basketball player.
He needed to complement
himself.
And that's again, going back
to this complementarity.
The coaches are there
to complement you.
Some coaches in the basketball
are just, how do
you play the game?
And some people are there,
what do you do
when you don't play?
And this is as important.
I have an adviser from a major
recruitment organization.
And he is actually there to tell
me how to pace myself,
because I overcommit.
And overcommiting is as
bad as overtraining.
So you need to find a balance.
And that's how you surround
yourself with the
right group of people.
DON DODGE: So how do
you find advisers?
Or how do you pick them?
Do you shoot for the stars and
try to get the best possible,
most prominent famous
person you can get?
Or do you look for someone who
has deep technical or deep
domain knowledge?
How do you choose
your advisers?
DAVID GURLE: Once you have
identified the areas that you
need help--
and before I give more
specifics, I think you need to
have a master adviser,
somebody who you
can call at any time.
And that person is going to be
really your day in, day out
person you interact with.
Then the rest of the
team has to be
specific to the functions.
It's good to have somebody who's
known in the industry,
because of two things.
Because a-- because they are
known in the industry, they
know what happens
in the industry.
And therefore, they're advice is
getting lots of information
and sanitizing and distilling
it to you.
So you don't have to go and
hunt for this information.
I think that's very valuable.
So you need to find somebody who
is a maven or who is a hub
in the world of potential
advisers, and also who's got
that human touch that you
can connect with.
A big name might be an excellent
idea, but if you
can't connect with that person,
I don't think it's
going to be useful, because it's
a personal relationship,
first and foremost.
And that's, I think, criteria
number one.
Criteria number two is, there
are lots of people in the
Silicon Valley and other places
where enterprises are
created who are willing
to give advice,
but nobody asks them--
seriously.
And so they all shoot
for the stars.
But there are plenty of stars
that sometimes you can't see
with the visible eye, but you
put a telescope, you can.
I think the analogy
is similar here.
There are lots of people with
great experience that you can
go and get help from.
And you need to network
with people.
You need to not hesitate
to ask.
You see somebody you like in
the domain that you are
looking for.
Are you open to advise me?
And most people will say yes.
And that's what you are looking
for, so that the
relationship and then finding
and not always looking for the
visible stars, but recognizing
that a universe of startups is
plenty of other stars.
And bringing them together is
what's going to make your
advisory board a
successful one.
DON DODGE: So the ideal advisory
board then are people
that you know and trust
and have a great
relationship with.
You try to get one general
adviser who's your go-to
person every day or every week
and then fill it in with two
or three others who might have
deep domain experience on a
particular topic?
DAVID GURLE: That
works for me.
And I think that's a balanced
advisory board.
It's really important
to have the
advisory board to be balanced.
You mentioned that I've been on
advisory boards myself in
my previous roles.
And what I have found, in some
instances, it worked really
well when the CEO of those
companies I was working with
were using the advisory board
as sounding advisory boards.
I think that's really
valuable.
But if you are using the
advisory board just to have
the prestige of names that you
are never going to talk to
during the life cycle of this
advisory board, I don't think
that's useful.
You need to, I think, be very
careful about the star chasing
syndrome that I have seen
in some instances.
DON DODGE: So there's a board
of directors, and there's an
advisory board.
So the board of directors is
normally your investors or
financial investors.
The advisory board may
not be an investor.
They're just there to help.
DAVID GURLE: In my case,
actually yes, some of my
advisory boards are investors.
And some of them are
here to help.
And the board of directors are
indeed, all investors.
That's the criteria I choose
when I created the company
that they have to be an investor
in order to be in the
board of directors.
DON DODGE: So you get different
advice from board of
directors versus an
advisory board?
DAVID GURLE: Absolutely.
And very interestingly, is
that it's two different
universes sometimes.
And again, it goes
back to being
judged versus not judged.
The board of directors, even if
in this case, I am also the
chairman of that board, you
still are in the context of
performance.
And the information you
convey and everything
is tainted by that.
In the advisory board, you are
just there to take advice.
So with that bias taken away,
the scope is very broad.
And therefore, you get a much
higher quality input.
DON DODGE: Well, this has been
a fascinating conversation.
I really appreciate
you being here.
DAVID GURLE: My pleasure, and
I wish all the existing and
tomorrow startups best of
success and surround
themselves with most
complimentary
advisory board members.
DON DODGE: Thank
you very much.
And that's Google Root Access.
We'll be with you
again very soon.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]